the digitalization of of latin america
has gotten to a critical point or a mass
critical point
where uh almost uh any business
would thrive uh locally for sure like i
can guarantee that
thank you so much for joining me how are
you i'm doing great michael thank you so
much for the invitation
of course so you're in colombia right
now right i'm in colombia in a small
town called
cincillejo most people wouldn't even
know what it is but if you're familiar
with colombia cartagena it's it's pretty
popular these days
so we're probably like three hours away
in the north coast of colombia that
would be
amazing once this whole pandemic is over
i'm accepted to travel meet you in
person
over there and see see what's happening
in colombia and one of the things that
you mentioned to me earlier is that
colombia is one of the
is a big tech hub of innovation there's
a lot of innovation happening around the
area
you yourself are so you're serial
entrepreneur
i've been involved with many companies
you've started your own your own
organizations that have grown
tremendously and i'm excited to hear
about
them but i want before all that you take
me back to you writing a book
on the history of international tourism
what the hell is that about yeah
that's super interesting i i think one
of my first
ventures or or ideas that came out of
you know me trying to do
entrepreneurship was that i really
really enjoyed uh tourism and that i
enjoyed
particularly ecotourism where you would
try to
have the least impact possible in in the
region where you are working at
uh and along that process what i
realized is that i wanted to promote
some of the tourism that i knew around
around the world because i had the
opportunity to travel this is around
like
10 years ago and uh when i'm doing this
process i of course knew that i knew
very little about tourism i thought i
knew and most people would think oh i
know a lot about tourism he's like no
you don't nothing
um and i ended up getting a scholarship
in in a university
in colombia uh to do my master's degree
in international business
uh but i didn't want to do this thesis
that you do
and like all the normal work that people
do so i was like can i do something
different
like something that i'm more more likely
to finish
and uh the book came to be an option and
i thought oh that's an amazing option
because then i can learn about all
different types of like tourism and what
is happening exactly
but it's it's it's really funny that you
asked about it because i never published
it
and my one of one of my teachers she's
um like a post doctorate like she's
actually really
good at this sort of thing she's like
you need to publish this book and just
because the pandemic was hidden
it was one of the things that really
came back to me it's like well a lot of
people are like oh i should write a book
i'm like
i wrote one i just need to publish it
now
so where is it when can i buy it when
can i get it and read it
i think i have um and and it's very good
that you all also
asked this question because i just
finished kind of like planning
the upcoming quarters and years to come
not years to come but like if i'm
lucky to get to the next three years and
one of the things that i put down
was that i need to publish and a
specific number of books
and i was like i'm gonna do this one and
there is a low hanging fruit here for
exactly and my main objective in the
next two quarters is to first update
whatever was in the book because things
have changed in the past like 10 years
um and because of the pandemic it just
become much more relevant
so i was like i think it's the perfect
timing for me to like get this book out
and then
get some momentum towards my goal for
the next five years
and obviously international tourism in
2021 is going to be i think one of the
most
interesting things to research because
you have you know a world that is
becoming more globalized people love
traveling and exploring new
people and ideas and all of a sudden
that comes to a halt we all go to
inside and now there's hopefully going
to be a resurgence of this
so i'm excited to read it just please
let me know when it's out but eddie and
now i'd love to hear about your
entrepreneurial journey because besides
from
from writing history books you're also
an entrepreneur yourself
you run a few organizations you help
other
entrepreneurs and founders create create
and run their businesses
so give me a little bit of a round down
and this time go back all the way to you
selling chocolate what was that about
awesome
so i i think i think i realized i was
what i had entrepreneurial tendencies
i realized i had entrepreneurial
tendencies when i was maybe
six years old uh because i would i would
take like my toys
and and then i would sell them to buy my
friends toys
in like uh like in kindergarten and like
primary school
so take it like they'll i remember like
buying with my
like saving my allowance to be able to
buy a toy to then resell that toy
like very very early age and then as i
became older i
i and i would call this like the basic
like
commerce like basic entrepreneurship
that you can do which is like i
buy something cheaper sell it more
expensive like there's not
much more to it you add maybe some value
in some way
and that's when i when i started doing
some things and chocolate
just became a thing in high school
because you were first of all not
allowed to sell chocolates in high
school
uh because uh there was a monopoly on
the business
which was the school cafeteria so
you we had to take down the big guy um
and and i was selling
i wouldn't i wouldn't take books to
school i would uh sell chocolate by my
uh
my differentiating component was that i
gave
credit uh the kids that were selling
other types of uh uh or candy were not
giving credit and i was given a lot of
credit with chocolate
and at some point um you know the legal
system came upon us
and the company was dismantled in in
mere days
it disappeared but it allowed me to to
to
prove a lot of things i bought a lot of
like soccer gear i remember buying like
guitar strings and like back then like i
come from from a humble
background and it was very difficult to
like get money and for me to have
money uh became a thing so money was
kind of like the driver in those early
days
so you found a product you got product
market fit you managed to sell to people
and you managed to be successful and
it's successful enough that you had the
big guys coming and shutting you down
and so you know during high school you
already experienced
pretty much the lifetime of of most
startups
so so what happens later how do you
continue on your entrepreneurial journey
i would say it's um it's become
or it's been a discovery process along
the way
because i didn't know these terms
i didn't know what entrepreneurship
meant in fact
you know my my first goal uh when i was
a teenager like doing this these
businesses or not i wanted to be a
doctor
i wanted to study biochemistry i wanted
to anything to do in fact i was gonna
i was gonna pursue a degree in
biochemistry and most of my family they
are doctors in
uh chemical engineering in mechanical
engineering uh
or doctors in in law or different things
so that they mostly pursue academics
uh and for me it just it seemed at some
point that it didn't fit
and i went to college but i i changed
like last minute i didn't do
biochemistry i went for international
business and
i went for international business
because it seemed kind of like the most
generic thing that would not take me in
any specific
path and along that process uh when i
was doing international business and a
little bit of economics
i get very involved in social
entrepreneurship there are different
projects going on
around the school in my hometown in
since alejo because you know if you're
studying internationally and you come
from a small town
it becomes very important that you kind
of like bring back some of the things
that you're learning
and then i start realizing that some of
my friends have some of those tendencies
so what we used to start doing is
projects that would uh be sustainable
over time uh to allow uh
vulnerable communities to to gain
benefits out of whatever it is that we
were doing and specifically
what we tried in in most of the cases
was to teach
something to to kids or or more
privileged kids of a town
let's say new delhi will be new daily
teaching english or we'll be in new
delhi doing certain activities that will
generate
or give us money so that we could give
them scholarships
to kids from poorer areas uh that could
go and do something else and
this is teenagers doing this and that is
no excuse of course teenagers today
are are much more advanced than we went
but we were back then we're talking
2006.
so uh 2000 exits like there was no there
was no like like smartphones that like
internet was seldom used
and it was very difficult for us at the
time to communicate different things but
we were
we went to these towns and we did these
projects
after that i decided to come back to
colombia
because i'm very romantic about those
things i believe that i'm
very well positioned to generate impact
uh
in my hometown specifically and i always
dream of coming back to my hometown
which is a later story but uh when i
come back to columbia i visit bogota and
then i visit medellin my sisters are
living in medellin
and then i start working in whatever it
is i could find
until i could find different things that
i could
actually pursue as an entrepreneur the
first thing that i pursued as an
entrepreneur
was tourism so because of that i i
connect with the university i start
doing
my master's in international business
with a focus on tourism and we uh
co-found something called tukaribe which
is an operator
the operator basically what it does is
that it creates touristic packages and
then it's sold to bigger places
but this is once again like basic kind
of like commerce like we create a
product and then we sell it but i
remember back then and this
we were talking in 2010 um nobody was
doing seo
back then nobody nobody tried to do that
and we started doing some articles to
kind of like pursue and i remember that
back then
you had like black hat and white hat seo
and then what i decided was that we have
to be white how we have to add value and
this whole silicon valley mentality that
today comes kind of
like sounds cliche but it definitely
like changed the way in which
many entrepreneurs did business uh 10
years ago and
maybe maybe more than today but but in
that process then i find
who became at that point in 2012 14
my first kerfuk official partner uh in a
venture called public science
actually the first venture was espacio
which espacio was a co-working space
in the city of medellin back then there
was there were no working spaces and i
remember
my partner asking me like where can we
go to a co-working space in medellin
and i was like i don't know what i could
work in spaces and then he explains it
to me and i'm like
this needs to be assisted like who was
the who is the genius that did this
he's thinking of starting a co-working
space and then that's the first venture
that we start together and then the
second one
is publicize and publicize uh exists
because of a need in the startup world
where
you have to get visibility for your
startup you always need to get
visibility for your startup
the system is not creative for that
really uh the system is created for
large companies to get visibility
because of
right you know the markups and etc etc
so publishers became
one of the first companies or agencies
in the world to work directly with
startups
and what did the what this did
uh in in you know the the seven or so
years
working uh with startups was that it got
me
really involved with a lot of different
business models
a lot of different startup communities a
lot of different
different places where there was no
technology and then it it exploded i
remember
and i can give you some examples uh
medellin is one of those cases
where 10 years ago there was pretty much
nothing and today you have an
organization called rutaene that is
devoted
to attracting innovation and talent to
the city to create
startups and i really what happened in
those 10 years
because 10 years is nothing it's nothing
in the scope
obviously of history of mankind but but
even in the scope of you know technology
it's you know it seems like nothing but
but so much
has happened in the pa passengers i'm
i'm still thinking i'm still reflecting
on what you said that 10 years ago
people weren't doing seo you know i grow
up
and you know in generation x or y or
whatever it is and
to me like if you don't have good seo
you're nothing you know on the online
world so so it's unbelievable to me but
what happened in these 10 years that
the columbia innovation hub really took
off
i think i think what happened is um
there was a generational change if you
think about it 10 years ago
a lot of the 15 year olds are getting
exposed
to technology or getting exposed to
different business models like
very early in their lives like if i was
to think like when i was 15 years old
being exposed to the idea that
a facebook existed like i don't know
where my mind would be like
i get goosebumps thinking about it
because it's it's it's incredible
and then you you see that first of all
the generational change that i actually
believe is like every five years
when one like i have my my niece she's
ten like
five years from now she's like she's a
productive human
and what i'm thinking is that's what's
happening in in latin america a lot of
productive humans are coming with with a
tech-savvy
um that allows them to do so much more
than they were
to do like 10 years ago a lot of people
became
very aware of the the the advantages of
digitalization and and it is
still a place where you can
create pretty much any e-commerce you
can think about
and make some money so this this this
the digitalization of of latin america
has got into a critical point or a mass
critical point
where uh almost uh any business
would thrive uh locally for sure like i
can guarantee that
um and compete even at national levels
and and what had happened or what
happened sorry
in the past 10 years is that
local startups national startups have
become much more competitive
towards external or or larger startups
coming from different countries and
that's why
uh you see now on amazon trying to like
get into latin america but mercado libre
which people thought oh it's dead now
amazon is gonna
you know destroy them is like no
actually they are thriving
and then you start looking at other
examples of startups that you know
are two three five years old and are
today getting
much more funding than any startup that
might be coming from
the united states trying to you know
have some operations
in in latin american countries so i i
that example by the way
really reminds me of you know jack ma's
biography talks about
the the competition between alibaba and
ebay in china right and at the end of
the day ebay comes in
with a giant 100 million dollar account
to spend to conquer the chinese market
and yet you have the scrappy two million
dollar funded startup out of jack ma's
apartment or his co-founders apartment
that are saying no no we know the market
we know the people we know the culture
and we are
and obviously they came out on top uh
and so i i can definitely understand and
i think that
from an author's perspective it also
makes perfect sense to me that you know
in this 10 years
uh 10 10 years that happened you have
this all of a sudden this
this insurgents of of innovation among
the youth
that are coming and saying wow like
there's such big market gaps between
what's happening here in latin america
versus what's happening around the world
especially in like you know the in north
america that there are just so many
opportunities to it's like low-hanging
fruit that you can just come and take
and implement
proven models maybe you have to do some
cultural shifts but
but proven models in consumer behavior
that could potentially work
absolutely and i think it's it's part of
the that's how an ecosystem works
i i think at the very beginning of the
process a lot
of uh entrepreneurs were thinking of how
am i the next
uh elon musk how am i jeff bezos and
he's like
no you can't be like there's no next
like
you are the next you uh and and a lot of
entrepreneurs have come to terms with
that
and and before i remember there was a
lot of conversation about like the
copycats oh it's so bad to be a copycat
it's like
well it depends what you're up to do
right it's not a bad thing or a good
thing
it's dependent on your purpose in life
and a lot of the entrepreneurs i think
today are thinking
more on what it is that they are looking
for
in life what is the impact that they are
trying
to uh achieve in the world uh and then
just try to align that icky guy
and everyone talks about the icky guy
and then you start seeing this
purpose is is a very powerful force and
i think the entrepreneurs in latin
america started realizing that
stop romanticizing business like the
moment you stop romanticizing business
you really start thinking about okay are
we making money why are we not making
money
fine end that conversation why are we
doing this is this
important to me is this important to
society if it's not
then like then do it for the money fine
like it's okay and i tell that to like
local entrepreneurs here all the time
all the time because you're like oh i
just want to make money very quickly i'm
like okay
entrepreneurship is not the place to
make money very quickly but
sell sell alcohol open a bar everyone
wants to drink so
you'll have cash flow and you'll be fine
if that's what you want to do but then
a few years from now you'll feel empty
and you'll think why am i empty and it's
like the reason why you're empty
is because it's not about the money
whether you get like 100 million dollars
in funding today
or you don't get a single dime and you
are in this process of entrepreneurship
what you will realize is that that is
not the center of the conversation
and the moment you open yourself up to
that reality is the moment when you
become free
and when you are free there is just a
flow
of creativity of a passion
of energy of respect
uh um that allows you to not only
convince yourself of your purpose but
also convince others
of your purpose and when you do that
you're creating
a company that is the ultimate uh
objective
eddie i just love that what is the
impact that you want to make as an
entrepreneur yourself
what how do you answer that difficult
question of what type of
impact you want to have on the world
i i think every entrepreneur is very
ambitious and
and dreams of things that they could
help achieve or achieve
by themselves um
i hope to be able to build a legacy
that is long-lasting
that allows for society to
thrive and that pursues
above all things the success of life
and and i'm very particular with that
because we are just a life
form and i think uh
understanding life has become a passion
of mine
and of course plants uh and and
vegetables and fruits and animals are
attract me a lot um so i'm hoping that i
can gain a much better understanding
and i hope in the next five years on on
how how for example
we can create a much more sustainable
world
so so above all else i i'm hoping that
the legacy that is left behind whether
it's in gastronomy
or i don't know whatever it is i i don't
know the future
but whatever it is and i'm working on
several things right now but whatever
that that
is that that legacy really is
long-lasting
and and that as a society we can say
that that was worth spending some time
on
and that i can agree with that uh um if
society doesn't agree with that today or
in the next 10 years well maybe that
that could
be possible but but at least to me that
has to be true
and i'm hoping is is is a legacy that
can be long lasting
eddie that was inspiring thank you so
much for being so generous with your
time 20 minutes
flies by especially when we're having
fun so it's unbelievable that it's
already over but before we leave i have
to ask you for the most important
question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
um the three words that would describe
me today um
would be genuine romantic
and calm i love that
i love that thank you so much eddie stay
safe stay healthy
this was just wonderful thank you thank
you michael have a great day